so hello everybody I would like to
introduce you to Alistair Roberts
Alistair some of you might have seen him
he did a review of my brother met Seuss
book and I've been kind of he's been
kind of floating around the same circles
as I you know because he talked about
symbolism he has a blog and a podcast
called allister's adverse adverse area
he works for the Theophilus Institute in
relationship with James V Jordan and
Peter lathe Hart and these are all I
would say a group of Protestant thinkers
that are trying to think symbolically
and so there's some interesting things
happening in those circles I was right
away when I started doing public
speaking someone kind of plugged me into
Jane B Jordans book through new eyes
which I which I read a large part of a
knife and I thought was very interesting
because it really did kind of coincide
with some of the ideas that I had that
mentor had and that we were discovering
also in in the church fathers and so I'm
really looking forward to talk to him
about his own symbolic discovery
symbolic view and also the resemblances
and differences between the way that
that I approach thing and also the way
that Orthodox approach things
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world so Alistair maybe you can
give a little introduction to yourself
kind of how you came into this world of
symbolism and this way of interpreting
the Bible and then we'll go from there
well I was raised in the Republic of
Ireland my father is a pastor and he had
a tremendous library huge library over
10,000 books at one point and I always
was interested in theology but I started
out on the direction of maths and
philosophy at university and then found
myself reading theology on the way to
university on the bus and it just caught
my attention it was something that I was
passionate about and at the time I was
really having a bit of a spiritual
awakening and so at that time I got into
theology and it about a year or two
after that I started looking through my
dad shelves came across a book called
through new eyes which you've already
mentioned by James B Jordan picked it up
and leaf through it for a while and just
thought this is weird and put it back
and then a while later I picked it up
again and read it and my whole way of
reading the Bible changed I think the
main thing that excited me about the
book is its use of symbolism its use of
typology and these are the figural ways
of approaching the text to show that the
biblical narrative really contains a lot
of theological import and content and
I've not really found my way out of that
rabbit hole yet I've been looking into
understanding the theology of biblical
narrative in a lot more detail reading
through Old Testament text getting into
the Gospels and what I've been trying to
do is communicate this in a way that is
accessible to people and in a way that
gets people excited about this too so my
PhD was on the relationship with between
baptism and the Red Sea crossing
between liturgy and typology and since
then I've written a book on echoes of
Exodus exploring the theme of Exodus as
it plays out throughout the Bible are
particularly focused upon narrative
structures and patterns so it's related
to symbolism but maybe more a matter of
typology yeah well I think to me the the
crux of symbolism in Scripture at least
the way that I approach and my brother a
little bit less because he tends to he
wanted especially in his first book to
stay in the Old Testament and really use
the Old Testament and show its coherence
and its structure whereas myself I tend
to always use Christ as the lid to the
fulcrum and always in trying to show how
everything kind of points towards him
and so he's he's my guide through the
Old Testament and it doesn't mean that
there isn't a variety of symbolism and
and a variety of elements pointing to
different things but I always kind of
use Christ as my my let's say guide as
I'm reading the Old Testament one of the
things that I find interesting is that I
I think we have seen we have seen in
let's say the 19th century and the early
20th century we have seen Protestants
discover patterns narrative patterns in
Scripture but for some reason this was
used almost in a subversive manner like
you know in a very very liberal
Protestant world and this idea of be
mythology the mythologizing the text
where they would see the patterns and
then they would use the patterns to say
see how this is you know like we need to
get rid of this like we because it's
it's actually because it has a pattern
you know it's pointing away from the
historical thing where it's pointing
away from from the you know from what
actually happened that type of thinking
whereas what I'm excited to see in your
in your work and what Jamie Jordan is
doing is no it's rather it's diving into
the patterns in order to see how
precious and beautiful and powerful it
is you know and and how it is helping us
understand the New Testament as well I
think one of the influences that has
been very significant in the development
of typology is a renewed attention to
the literary character of the biblical
narratives that these aren't just
blow-by-blow accounts of just events
there's a presentation of the events in
a very structured and careful way
to help you recognize symmetries
connections themes that connect things
together and the way that these things
resonate with past events and that sort
of influence has come from a number of
different sources whether the work of
people like richard hayes or his work on
echoes of scripture and the God in the
letters of Paul and echoes of Scripture
and the Gospels more recently or people
like Robert alter the art of biblical
literature and other Jewish sources
where there has been this attentiveness
to the biblical text and the way that
stories are told and I think one of the
ways in which this has really hit the
ground has been in context where people
have been trying to develop an
understanding of the authority of
biblical narrative and realizing that
the way that we read biblical narrative
is very thin that there's just not much
to it and so people trying to get into
the depth of biblical narrative say why
has God given us this in the first place
and then when you start to notice the
patterns you begin to realize well maybe
there's a reason for these patterns and
those patterns are the breadcrumbs that
lead you to greater theological insights
I believe and so following those
literary patterns through to deeper
theological reading of the text
recognizing the unity of the text and as
you point out that ultimately all of
this leads to Christ it's in that sense
a figural reading becomes a trans
figural reading and and I've likened it
to walking a path where at many points
you can only see it a few and steps
ahead or you might be walking through
woods and you can't see long into the
distance but occasionally through the
leaf cover you can aspire this distant
mountain and that great peak is the
point that you're working towards but
much of the time you can't see it and
then you walk through rocky terrain
following the path and then finally you
ascend this great mountain and then from
the vantage point at the top everything
unfolds as a unified itinerary and from
that perspective I think our
understanding of Christ as
that which is the vantage point from
which the whole text opens up I think
that has been a very important I suppose
it's the destination of a true literary
reading of the text yeah so the literary
reading helps us to follow the path
itself not just to jump straight to the
mountaintop and miss the significance of
the path right exactly but actually to
hold those things together so what I've
seen in your work and in in Jordan's
work you know and even in let Hart's
work is I really see some insights it's
some powerful insight sometimes some
things that I had thought about some
parallels that I haven't even seen or
that it seems like no one has seen
before that are that are being brought
about and shown in these different lines
and threads and and so I've gathered
some insight from even your work or
James Jordans work one of the questions
I have though is you know you can do it
from a literary standpoint where you see
the the Bible and you look at how all
these literary patterns work their way
and kind of lead up towards Christ as
the culmination of the of the story you
could say one of the contentions that
I've had and that my brother materias
also had is that this pattern that you
see that leads to Christ is not only a
literary pattern that leads to Christ
but it is also ultimately the pattern by
which we actually encounter reality that
it is it is showing us the manner in
which reality unfolds it's reality
itself unfolds and so the by the glasses
that you get from training in Scripture
are actually the best glasses to have to
look at the world around you and to
notice the patterns that are appearing
in the world and so I don't know if
that's something that that you or some
of your group have also talked about or
worked on but very much agree with that
the the patterns that we're reading are
not mere literary patterns they are
literary patterns but when we see that
sort of analogy between different levels
of reality the ways in which characters
are likened to each other or we see
themes and motifs playing out again and
again it's something about reality
itself and I think the key aspect of
reality that we're being exposed to is
the work of the Holy Spirit the holiest
is that which unifies the medium of time
and the Holy Spirit bears things along
through time and connects things
together in a unified work and so for
instance if we're reading the creation
account of Genesis 1 it's told in a
poetic form but the poetry is fitting to
the reality because the world is poetic
the world has these symbolic and
typological structures as part of it and
so poetry helps us to see the ways the
different parts of reality resonate with
each other how they're not detached and
just objects within space and time but
there is this unity of the dance of
reality that God has established and the
Holy Spirit's orchestration of reality
the orchestration of time so time is not
just one thing after another but is a
unified movement and there is a musical
character to it
I've often returned to that metaphor of
music to understand the way time when we
think about the exploration of time
music is brob is perhaps the richest and
the strongest purchase that we can have
upon time conceptually music is
something that can connect different
times together in very powerful and
immediate ways so it's not just clock
time the succession of instance that can
divide two events but rather two events
can be brought together in a very
powerful way through musical connections
and there are ways in which times can be
charged by music even silences are not
absent places of absence and non
presence they can be places of the
deepest and most pregnant presence when
there is reality surrounding them and
framing them and in the same way and
think in Scripture we're seeing out
these patterns playing out through time
in a musical way that ultimately lead to
this great crescendo and then that works
out in the aftermath in the life of the
church mm-hmm one of the things that it
has opened up for me as well is that
discovering that and under
standing the let's say understanding how
the patterns laid themselves out how
narrative patterns laid themselves out
and then also how they culminate in
Christ what had it say one of the things
that is freed for me is that using my
anchor like keeping hold on my anchor
which is Christ I feel like I'm less
threatened by other stories as well you
know because one of the one of the
attacks that have been launched on
Christians you know for 200-300 years
has been how similar the story of Christ
is to you know picking out stories from
other mythologies and showing how this
aspect of Christ's story resembles this
one and this you know and and so to me
that has acts now it's it's like yeah
bring it on you know this is great I
don't have a problem with any of this I
actually think that it is wonderful the
thing they don't realize is how actually
Christ unites all these stories together
and when the reasons why you can see
aspects of Christ in different gods and
different different mythological
structures is that actually they're all
jammed into this one mask this one story
and this one character that that is you
know a king and and and an outcast and
you know and he's an agriculturist but
he's also a shepherd and he's he has all
these he's pulled all these at these
strings of reality it's kind of brought
them into one character and that idea of
Christ as as Lewis talked about is true
myth I think that's part of Christ's
Redemption that he can take up all the
stories and bring them to their full and
complete resolution in himself and if we
just had Christ as one particular type
of story that and didn't really have the
ability to comprehend the full variety
and variegation of human story I think
he wouldn't be the true archetype that
he is I think Christ as the word is the
one who can take up all the words and
take them into himself one of the
questions that I had is is how do you
your group how do you and your group how
do you relate to the church fathers
because I one of the things that I've
been trying to do is to try to open up
for people once again the typology which
you find in
you know I I have my main characters
which I'm always pushing the same the
same the same writers and Ephraim's and
I st. Gregory of Nyssa and say Maximus
but there's also you know the early mr.
mr gandhi's of the church there are
different or the mystic ages that do
that that I could also point to so how
how has your exploration been affected
or not by those types of readings I
think the church fathers are incredibly
important in what they emphasize is the
vantage point from which the church
reads the Scriptures so they stress and
as I think Robert Charles put it the
Dominical warrant to read the Old
Testament in the light of Christ so
Christ has called us to see him in all
the scriptures and the Church Fathers
recognizing and taking that authority
have gone to throughout the Old
Testament and seen Christ within it
stories I think the Protestant concern
has generally been the concern that you
can make the text into whatever you want
now arguing for the church fathers I
don't think that's what they're doing is
not just taking an allegorical approach
as such to the text it's taking the
biblical warrant given by Christ to the
text and seeing him where he has told us
that he is to be seen
the problem however is how can you be
sure that you are seeing Christ in the
text itself and not just projecting
projecting Christ into the text and so
the Reformation was very much a return
to the literary the literal or literary
sense of the text actually getting into
the order of the word the grammatical
sense the historical sense and then
trying to work from that ideally to
something beyond that the figural the
allegorical sense and then to the other
senses that medieval and patristic
writers have highlighted I think the
danger is that for many people after the
Reformation the whole quest became
stymied in the literal sense they never
actually went beyond that and one of the
things that we're trying to do I think
within the circles I'm operate
is to recover something of the
Christological and allegorical and
typological reading that the Church
Fathers exactly exemplified within the
framework of disciplined grammatical
historical approach to the text so we're
reading the text itself in a literary
way paying attention to the phrases that
have used the details that are put in
the literary structures and then from
that seeing that that elicits the sort
of reading that the fathers were
pointing us to now I think the fathers
were often a lot more sophisticated than
we give them credit and they recognized
the way that the literal sense naturally
produces that sort of typological or
allegorical reading and the allegorical
reading was not just projected onto the
text and if you yeah so for instance in
my work on the Red Sea crossing and
Christian baptism I was constantly
thinking about some of the ways the
early church fathers were using Old
Testament texts to illumine the practice
of baptism and they were recognizing
what the Apostles themselves recognized
that there is an analogy between and the
Red Sea crossing and Christian baptism
and they're exploring that in all sorts
of ways often with a more and
retrospective force than the prospective
force that poured users for instance in
1st Corinthians 10
so Paul very much focuses upon and the
baptism of the Red Sea crossing as that
which leads into the wilderness
experience whereas for the Church
Fathers the tendency tended to be to
look back to the deliverance from Egypt
and that's what the Red Sea crossing
marks the Pharaoh of Satan has been
drowned within the deep and the demons
and the sins that are pursuing us and
all of this is enacted within liturgy
helps us not just to see this story as
something that is over against us as
this just a narrative on a page but as
something that we're called to inhabit
as the people of God and call to enter
in particularly through the practice of
baptism and the supper and that way of
reading
tax which is connected to the practice
of liturgy and the church's life I think
is something that we tried to recover
but within the context of the discipline
of grammatical historical exegesis I
think it's interesting I mean I think
that there's definitely some fruit there
in what you're saying and and in a
certain manner that's what I'm doing and
in the sense that I'm explaining
symbolism and but I think that the fact
that we're explaining symbolism is a
actually a sign of a disease you know
it's actually a sign that we have to
administer a cure when I read let's say
the Saint Gregory of nYSSA's life of
Moses what I see is that he's he's
actually participating in the story and
so he's doing it in a poetic manner and
so he is not he's not just going into
the text and then finding the structures
he is himself creating poetic structures
narrative poetic structures that he is
so he's going back in the Old Testament
connecting it with Christ doing it in a
poetic manner which is participating in
the meaning making and in the let's say
the the celebration of that pattern you
know and so I found that in saint
gregory of nyssa sometimes they're such
subtle things that he says that you
don't that you have to approach that
Gregory of nYSSA's text with the same
attention that you would have to
approach reading Exodus itself because
he will say he will string a sentence
together where he will talk about the
Egyptians and the foreign and the
foreskin and baptism and he is key and
and and the bitterness of the waters and
he'll string all of that together in one
one phrase where he has created a a
sentence that is not only pointing back
to the Old Testament point to the New
Testament but creating the music itself
not just analyzing the music and I think
that that is you know sometimes I I
realize that what I'm doing in a way is
very much less than what the fathers
were doing because I am explaining it
rather than I'm trying and I in my icon
carving and I'm in my art I try then to
have participate in
music as much as I can but there is a
way in which we have to me that it's
important that we do so that that is
also I guess what kind of brings me to
the question of liturgical life and the
surgical practice and how that fits
together so I don't know what what your
tradition is exactly but I'd like to
hear a little bit about how you feel
that this new discovery is informing the
liturgical life of your of your
tradition I think that's a really
important question because as you point
out there is an immediacy to the text
and it's patterns that you see within
the Church Fathers that as I noted
earlier that all of this is explored
within the context of the liturgy and
the sacraments so you explore the
connections between the Red Sea crossing
and Christian baptism in the context of
the performance of Christian baptism not
in an abstract theological discourse now
that doesn't mean there's no place for
the abstract theological discourse but
it's a very second-order discourse it's
there to support the primary practice
and I think part of this is the problem
of our concept of what the Scriptures
are we I'm I often give the illustration
of what is a Shakespearean play and to
many people if you asked what is a
Shakespearean play they would point to a
book off the shelf that they would read
in a high school English class and say
that's Hamlet that's a Shakespearean
play but a better answer would be to
take someone into a theatre and point at
what's taking place on the stage and say
that's a Shakespearean play now behind
that play is a script that people have
carefully studied they've memorized
they've taken that word into themselves
and they've also reflected upon the
meaning of the text how to express this
in the most faithful way to
Shakespeare's original intent and to
express it in a way that brings that to
life through performance and I think
that's very much like the church's
experience we're often in the danger I
think this is particularly an issue for
Protestants who are people who have been
defined by spending time with the Bible
as a book and with the rise of
the Bible has a physical book that is
privately-owned printed bound and
between two covers etc words on a page
but yet to actually engage with the text
the true home of the text is the liturgy
and that before the books were bound in
single cover in a single panned act we
don't have many pan decks from the early
centuries it's only fairly late on that
we have that and chapters and verses of
fairly late editions
all of these things are later things
that arose around the text to very much
conform the text to the eye rather than
the ear and the public performance and
hearing and so the context for reading
the Psalms is singing in a company of
people the context for hearing the story
is hearing and performing within the
context of the liturgy and the
sacraments and so we recount the story
of the exodus within context of things
like the celebration of the Eucharist
and that is the true home for the text
and so part of what we need to do I
think as a necessary complement to a
more symbolic and topological reading of
the text is to recover it's true
liturgical home that the true binding of
the text is the church church's life now
one of the important things that the
Protestant tradition has tried to
emphasize is the place of the scripture
as a corrective voice over against the
church so if the church is like the
people performing a Shakespearean play
the text always retains that character
of a script something written that can
stand over against isn't challenge it
but with ever without that engagement
with a script that's detached from us
either usurping the primary form of
engagement which is that's the
inhabitation of the text within us the
word is supposed to come become flesh it
become flesh in Jesus Christ and within
his people we're supposed to be the
epistles of Christ as Paul talks about
in 2nd Corinthians chapter 3 and 4 so
within the liturgy and the sacrum
that's where the text takes flesh in us
our bodies are conscripted by the word
and we play out these patterns in a way
that shows very clearly that we belong
to the text and the text has assumed our
world that it's well the world that
surrounds us has retold refigured
reconfigured in the light of the
coordinates of the text now within the
Protestant tradition this is struggle
because on the one hand you have a more
highly liturgical context and things
like Django Catholics on the other hand
you have the Bible centered evangelicals
and low church groups and actually
finding a way to marry a very deep
concern with the authority of Scripture
and the centrality of Scripture with a
more liturgical sensibility and a
recognition of the importance of the
life of the church in its practices and
symbols as the true home of the text
marrying those two things is difficult
so the Protestant tradition has both of
those things but they tend to be
alienated from each other
so within much of the work that I'm
doing and things like the Theophilus
Institute are doing we're trying to
bring those two things together to get
people excited about liturgy again to
recognize that liturgy is not just
window dressing but hisses it is
integral to scriptural practice if we're
going to be faithful to Scripture this
requires liturgy it requires an
inhabitation of the text and we don't
think about the text carefully enough in
its distinctive character I mean you
don't read a recipe book just next to
your bedside table you perform it now
the Bible is so much more than that the
Bible is I mean the Bible itself is much
not necessarily the best word to use the
Scriptures are a word that we're
supposed to be performing a word that
we're supposed to be recounting and
memorializing these greats event events
of God recognizing that we are part of
the story to write so I guess this then
leads to the big question I guess the
big question is that the question of
sacramentality itself
and the reality of the sacraments one of
the things that we saw happen in the
modern age you know not in all
Protestant traditions in the same at the
same level but let's say as a general
pattern has been the because of because
of a loss of the symbolic worldview
where there's an integration of image
and this and this understanding of
patterning and how we participate in the
patterns as being in the image of God
there has been a desire to make first
the sacraments only allegorical or only
symbolic in a very negative sense where
there's the idea that there's a base
reality which is objective and and let's
say how can I say this like there's
there's like a base historical or part
thing reality which is which is solid
and then there's a kind of pointing to
to some other thing and and it's and
it's disconnected whereas the symbolic
worldview tend to want to connect things
and you know participative patterns and
so how has this let's say affected your
vision or the people that you're around
how has it affected your vision of the
sacraments and of sacramentality I think
one of the more distinctive Protestant
emphasis is upon oh you have a variety
of different Protestant approaches some
would be very strong on real presence
for instance within the Eucharist if you
talk to many and anglo-catholics high
church or high church and Anglicans if
you talk to Lutheran's and if you talk
to traditional reformed Christians
you'll often find this emphasis upon the
real presence but alongside that in the
more widespread popular movements there
tends to be a denial of real presence as
more more memorial lists or merely
symbolic understanding now when we talk
about merely symbolic the problem there
is the merely reality itself is
structured by symbols so it's not as if
there's any symbol that's merely simple
symbol there's something I mean a symbol
is something that is at the very core of
reality symbol is that which represents
the fibers of real
to buy which things are connected so I
don't think that it is wrong to think
about the sacraments in terms of
symbolism I just think the mere
symbolism is a problem right now
Protestants I think have emphasized more
the temporal and personal dimensions of
the sacraments those have tended to be
where their emphasis emphases lied
particularly within the more evangelical
tradition so within the evangelical
tradition its focused upon not so much
the host as the host that Christ is the
one who stands in our midst as we're
celebrating and we as we remember him he
is the one who invites us to his table
etc he's present with us now I think
that's a in many contexts it ends up a
very thin understanding of what is
actually taking place what typology I
think it's it's best is trying to
recover is a sense of time itself as a
realm of participation and so time
itself is that which by the Holy Spirit
times that are far distance from each
other are held together by the music of
his work and so we truly participate in
the work of Christ much as you might
drop a stone into a pond and find the
ripples moving towards the shore so each
week we're caught upon those ripples and
drawn further towards the shore and
feeling the force of that original event
but it's a temporal movement that is
emphasized and the personal action of
Christ so it's not so much an emphasis
upon spatial and visual and substantial
categories as an emphasis almost upon
the insubstantiality of reality we are
people who are caught up on the waves of
time by the spirit and it's that
temporal and participation that comes to
the fore now I think at its best that
can provide quite a thick account but we
need to think a lot more about what is
it that gives time it's reality how can
we have a thicker account of time itself
and afton that has been lacking with in
Protestant thought where often your
spatial
time to think about two times opposed to
each other New Covenant Old Covenant law
gospel associations with that or at the
age to come and the present age whatever
it is but there's less of a sense of the
lively tensions and connections and
interplays between times and there I
think the work of the Holy Spirit really
needs to come into the foreground again
I think that's one of the things that
for instance carbon was trying to do
with his doctrine of the Holy Spirit
being far more central to his
understanding of the Eucharist
but it's not really been engaged with as
much as it should have been and I would
like to recover typology as that which
explains time itself as a realm of
participation that we are caught in the
slipstream of the Son of God and we are
being drawn into his image as all the
Old Testament history was drawn into his
slipstream and now we're being drawn
into the age to come as he has gone
before us he has split open the abyss of
death so that we might walk through on
dry ground mm-hmm well then I guess
since we're we you kind of brought us on
this subject I guess then the question
then comes to the question of body and
you know the the the question of space
you know and of architecture and of art
and everything because that is also one
of the things that has been tossed aside
not completely but let's say has been
very much marginalized in in the
Protestant tradition and so because you
see you know one of the things that I
saw in in in James V Jordans book and in
other of the these types of writings is
every of space in terms of the temple in
terms of the tabernacle and kind of an
understanding of how this is a cosmic
image it's not just it's not just an
arbitrary setup you know there is
actually is a a structure a cosmic
structure in the temple and in the
tabernacle and so and that is something
that at least the traditional church has
transformed and transmuted into what is
now the structure of the church the
tripart structure of the church which I
always tell people is not actually
looking
towards the Old Testament as people
think it's actually looking towards
revelation it's a there is no altar in
the Holy of Holies and in the Old
Testament the altar on which the lamb
appears that all are bowing towards is
in Revelation there's a there's a flip
which happens which it's not really a
flip it's more of bringing it all
together bringing the whole world into
the Holy of Holies is something that
happens in in the traditional Christian
liturgy show that the altar in the in
the Holy of Holies in the church is is
the altar but is also the Ark of the
Covenant at the same time it's both at
the same time it's also the table around
which we sit to eat it's also you know
it's it's it's all of these things kind
of jammed into just like Christ kind of
brings everything into himself we
reproduce that in our worship and so has
there been a let's say a rediscovery at
least maybe I understand that maybe
images is maybe pushing far pushing hard
on the products inside but you know in
terms of just reading their spatial
structure of the church has there been
some work done in that that respect
let's say I don't think there's been
enough done but I think you're right
that it is very important that
throughout the scripture there is an
emphasis upon architectural structures
we have the description of the creation
of the world is such a structure we have
the description of the Garden of Eden
that's another such structure the
tabernacle the temple and a number of
other such things all represent and
architectural structures we even see
these things in prophecies such as
Ezekiel in Ezekiel will give the
dimensions of this eschatological temple
and tell the people that they should see
it and mourn their sins because they
should see something symbolically within
that architectural structure that
testifies to their status and how they
stand relative to it we see the same
thing I think also in Revelation along
with liturgical structures that are
going on in heaven and then we're told
in Hebrews that there is this heavenly
tabernacle or temple that corresponds
with the earthly one that is a model of
that so we have heavenly models being
impressed upon earthly realities with
the intent that that earthly model would
spread out
and in fact the whole world now I think
within the design of churches
historically there has been a deep
appreciation of the significance of
physical structure so for instance the
ways that and on many different levels
they are formed to coordinate space so
you see for instance the church is a
landmark with the steeple that's
supposed to stand or or the dome
something that's supposed to stand to be
seen from all around to coordinate
places it's a sanctuary there's a sort
of concentric circle ordering of the
place in much the same way as you would
see within the tabernacle and there's
also the way that the church can be a
site of pilgrimage in many contexts it
serves as a node of destination for an
itinerary and in each and then it can be
a central seat for a diocese and the
cathedral seat and in all of these ways
it's a negotiation and coordination of
space so if you see a great cathedral
within a city often the whole city has
developed around that place the
cathedral or the Minster Church they
were often the first settlements yeah
and that established the whole sense of
spatial tea within regions so you have
the sites of pilgrimage and then the
routes of pilgrimage associated with
that you'd have the landmarks you'd have
putting down roots as well with all the
the graves and it's a sign that we
belong in this place and the life in
this place is ordered by this symbol
that draws our attention up but also
recognizes how deep the roots go down
and in all of these ways I think the
Protestant tradition has experienced a
thinning out of its understanding of
space part of this is simply because of
the way in which it's been negotiating
new realities and that's something
that's in common with other churches
that have experienced and technological
and social changes where we're building
societies around the car instead of
around people who are living their lives
on foot and horseback and that changes
the way things
are ordered the idea of the frontier
within the US it required and for
actually working in a very mobile
society the sort of system that maybe
the Methodists represented with a mobile
circuit where people are moving around
rather than the settled Paris system
that you have that developed over time
within Europe and these ways I think
we're facing new challenges but it's
been harder to develop a sense of
spatial tea within the context within
which will be working especially when we
become a church that has often reacted
too much against fetishization of images
and structures and moved against that to
a purging of the realm of the physical
of images of structures and these sorts
of things we see within the Old
Testament that there was that danger to
fascists that resize the structure of
the temple that the temple itself could
become idolatrous we see that in
Jeremiah and Ezekiel and but then we
also see the danger of even licit images
like the bronze serpent in first Kings
14 it becomes a sort of idolatrous
symbol now the Protestant reaction has
often been a sort of iconoclastic one
and certainly within the more
evangelical Puritan traditions and often
there's been a failure to recover a
sense of a healthy relationship with
spaciality with physicality with the
visible realm and also with our bodies
and that's one of the things that I
think we need to get back to
understanding for instance that God
claims our bodies and baptism and I
often try and tell people look at your
body think about your body and your body
is we often think about people as minds
that are detached from their bodies but
our bodies are the site in which we feel
guilt and shame is where we feel
mortality most keenly it's where we feel
exposure to other people all these sorts
of things and so if we think about our
bodies in that way
it should be all the more surprising
that God has declared our bodies to be
marked out for resurrection that he has
conscripted our limbs and our organs as
the ministers of Christ declaring not
just us as persons but our very hands
and our legs and our mouths as belonging
to him for his service and then finally
that we have it's our bodies that are
the temple of the Holy Spirit not just
the not just the soul but the body
itself has been claimed and so I think
Protestants have reacted against genuine
problems but there is a need to recover
some of the good things that may have
been thrown out along the way well one
of the things that I that I'm that I saw
like when I look at the modern story
that's a modern history and how
modernism developed and how from the
Reformation we kind of move forward it
seems like to me that the symbolic
question is the biggest one it in the
sense that the the the difficulty in
understanding symbolism or the
difficulty in understanding how
symbolism lays itself out and how we
participate in it has led people to see
patterns as almost bad in themselves
that there's that the very fact that
there's a pattern is is it's almost like
it's it's verging on idolatry you know
it's it's coming close to idolatry just
because there's a pattern and so that
has been true of that it seems to me
that that's why there's a desire to
destroy hierarchy or that it's an
implicit desire to kind of annul
hierarchy and and I think it depends
like you said it just did it also
depends because product Protestantism is
so wide like it's so vey if there's so
much of it but it seems like there's
that there's a little bit of that where
you and some of the let's say some of
the patterns that remain and some of the
hierarchies that remain they become like
unconscious they people don't realize
that they're there and you see that of
course you see that much less and let's
say something like an Anglican Church
like a high Anglican Church I definitely
speak more from my background which was
a kind of no conservative Baptist
background where you
No you could feel like even the fact
that there was a stage that everybody
looked at that there was a point was was
almost like a source of guilt for the
for the the church it was and they
didn't want to cross like nothing to
kind of to pull attention to itself you
know because everything had to kind of
be flat there's also like a weird idea
that somehow democracy is is a Christian
idea in itself like that somehow dim
democracy not just in terms of politics
but democracy in terms of just a way of
being where everything has a voice like
an equal voice and that is really
destructive to a symbolic worldview
because there is a natural like a
natural hierarchy of things which lay
themselves out in when you understand
patterns you can just they and and if
and if we are called to participate in
the fullness of Christ it doesn't mean
that it all gets annulled right it means
that we're brought into it you know but
the hierarchy doesn't disappear we're
actually Christ actually calls us to
participate and ultimately even to to
join him you know as high as possible in
that in that that ontological hierarchy
um so maybe this this will bring you to
I we've been going for a while so I'm
gonna ask you the hardest question this
is that this is gonna be the hardest
question for you just go to warn you so
that I guess the hardest the hardest
question now comes to two people like
two to two people let's say it and IVs
gonna come to Mary it's gonna come to
the question of Mary and understanding
because one of the things that
traditional Christians see as they see
the pattern is that they see that let's
say as the all the images point to
Christ but then in pointing to Christ
there's also an underlying thing right
it's like it it's like everything points
to the glory of God which is on the the
mercy seat in the in the temple right
but there's also the mercy seat and so
the mercy seat is the is the possibility
in which this this has this happens the
throne the the mercy seat the you know
you have all these these images
and so it to me it's because I had to go
through I had to make this work I had to
do this work myself I grew up protestant
so i had to do the work of understanding
okay so then what then what now and it's
the conclusion of the torrential
Christians came to is that that's the
mother of god that's that's Mary she is
all the places of of theophany in the
Old Testament you know are all culminate
in her as an image of course not not
just her as a just an individual her as
the the the mother her as the the
Theotokos the one who brings forth from
below you know up into the world and
then ultimately has an image of the
church and us together in communion
being that new body of Christ so I don't
know if if there is because I know
that's a most maybe that touchy
assumption but but has there been some
work to at least kind of think about it
and to to be able to perceive that that
this is part of the pattern or is that
not at all I think that you I'll let you
yeah obviously you won't sink your ship
it's an important question I think all
of the things that you are saying there
are in part getting back to fundamental
questions about how we relate the
universal and the particular and I think
the modern problem is that we have a
universal that raises all particularity
and so the hierarchy problem looms very
large because the universal would have
raised all hierarchy flatten out all of
reality whereas the biblical universal
is one that integrates and traverses all
particulars so we see that I think in
Christ that he's not just raising the
differences between men and women Jews
and Gentiles etc but rather integrating
all as one it's the unity that he formed
through traversing all of those things
now when we're talking about symbolism I
think we're talking about something DIF
we're talking about something similar
that symbolism is something that
integrates many different realities in a
unified one and recognizes how
different things that might seem to be
just diverse or meaningless because
they're just scattered particulars are
actually held into some unified whole
now when we're thinking about Mary the
question is how does the character of
Mary relate to all these other aspects
of Scripture now I think often for
Protestants the tendency has been to
minimize the connections to say that
Mary is not connected with all these
things in the Old Testament and the new
well if you're reading the story
carefully it seems clear to me that
she's connected with characters like
Miriam
Miriam's present at the birth and
deliverance of Moses and then she's
present at the later deliverance of the
whole people as they're drawn out of the
waters as Moses was Mary is present at
the birth she's also present at the
death of Christ and both of those events
kind of sum up Christ's significance
matches and Moses rescue in his birth
and then the rescue from the Red Sea sum
up his significance and she's also
someone who is sums up his rock a
certain respect she stands for Israel is
the one that has been waiting for
and then also welcomes and and opens to
Christ that Christ is and finds a home
in her his first home there's a
Pentecostal theme there as well that the
Holy Spirit overshadows Mary much as the
Spirit will overshadow the church on the
day of Pentecost and Mary is like Hannah
she's the one who sings the Magnificat
that calls back to the song of Hannah
she's the one who's blasted among women
like jail was in the song of Deborah and
in all these different ways she brings
together the stories and the events of
the Old Testament and they're mobilized
within her story and I think what we're
seeing there is not and this is where I
differ with Catholics and to a lesser
extent with Orthodox I've enjoyed some
Addison Hodges Hart book on the woman
the hour of the garden I found very
helpful on some of these themes
recognizing the way that as we
through the Gospel of John and she's
constantly just she's not spoken of by
name she's always the mother of Jesus
and she's playing deeply symbolic roles
within that but it's recognizing that
she is not the one upon all the symptom
all the symbolism and collapses and it
all points to her rather she stands as
the head of a larger reality the reality
of the church the reality of Israel and
is the Jerusalem above that is the
mother of us all in Galatians chapter 4
and so we have other persons in
Scripture that can stand for large
realities with that Moses or whether
it's Abraham and Sarah Sarah stands for
the entire people of God as the great
matriarch of Israel and you have Rachel
standing for great companies of people
in Jeremiah 31 and also in Matthew 2 and
I think Mary fits into that same sort of
mold she's someone who is one of the
foreground particular symbols in which
the reality of the lot or the larger
reality of the spirits work through the
church is condensed so it's where we
really see a as it were where the
iceberg of that greater reality can be
seen above the surface in her story and
so she's very important as an individual
person and then also as a symbol but I
don't want to collapse the reality of
the symbol which stands for much more it
stands for the whole company of the
people of God as the church the
Jerusalem a bar that stands for all the
women of scripture it stands for a much
greater reality of the believer as well
as the one who welcomes Christ into
themselves in all these ways she's
archetypal in some sense but I don't
want to deny the symbolism but nor do I
want to collapse the symbolism right
well it's interesting because it's it's
the way that I think that at least our
Orthodox we see it in it'sit's not so
much
a collapsing as a it's it's a it's an
incarnation of process I'm not saying
she's the incarnation of course not
but what I what I mean is that in the
church we have an incarnational reality
and so the the it's like we always talk
about how you know in the Old Testament
we have these these prototypes and then
we have the aunty types that come in the
reality of Christ and so it is not just
that let's say even not her eye not even
just her even st. Peter and st. Paul and
the Apostles and and some of the saints
it's not just that they that they point
to that they that they're that they're
stand-ins for a symbol but it's a
participative reality and that they're
actually engaging manifesting gathering
together a reality in in a way and in
the in the context of the mother of God
that gathering you know when she talks
about how she gathered all things in her
heart all these things in her heart that
to me is the image of the Incarnation
itself that is it is she she has
gathered the logos in her womb and then
the the ultimate manifestation has
appeared and so it is it's an ink it's
like an incarnation little process and I
guess that that will end up being the
biggest difference it say between us in
the sense that that also leads to our
own participative relationship with each
other in the Orthodox Church which is
why we we also celebrate saints that's
why we also engage with each other in
prayer and in and in mutual veneration
you know we you know we venerate each
other the priests the people we kiss
either the holy kiss in our tradition is
seen as a form of veneration like you
would kiss the gospel that's one thing
the awfulest has been trying to bring
back the proud case of a holy kiss okay
that we think it is important to
recognize the image of God in each other
and I think one of I would like to see
Protestants make a lot more of a move to
recognizing the importance of Mary and
the I mean when we think I mentioned
earlier the body as the temple of the
Holy Spirit
and Christ becomes flesh he he and
Tabernacles among us and we have lots of
Ark symbolism I think within the Gospel
of Luke and in that sense I think Mary
is very much functioning like an image
of the temple she is in that sense the
first temple and that we have in the new
testament the new temple
with Christ dwelling and Hermits with
the overshadowing spirit and there I
think I would want to use the language
of participation but when we're thinking
about the Old Testament and the New
Testament realities I wouldn't think so
much in terms of type reality or yeah
and type anti-type I think throughout
the Old Testament and into the new we
have larger realities that are being
expressed in many different iterations
of different degrees of participation
and in Mary I think we have a
particularly condensed expression of
that but there's the reality that she
expresses is far larger and it's one
that I think stands for the great
reality of the church and we all
participate in that and to an extent and
she is archetypal of every believer who
has bears Christ within their bodies
yeah all right now is there so I
appreciate your time and I will ask
everybody to to go check out your blog
I'll put all the links in the
description of your blog your podcast
and also the Institute that you're
involved in and I'm hoping you know I'm
hoping that this will be a space for a
discussion and kind of discovering
because I I think that the kind of
systematic approach that you're taking
and that James B Jordan is thinking I
think it actually it actually is
wielding good fruits you know some of
the you know some of the this rigorous
approach whereas if you read the Church
Fathers there's a more of an intuitive
it's like a more intuitive approach
where he this rigorous approach is
actually wielding some very interesting
results and so I will definitely be be
paying attention to what your what
you're doing and continue to and
hopefully we can have another discussion
at some point I very much enjoy that
thank you for having me on
no it's my pleasure if you enjoy the
symbolic world content there's a lot of
things you can do to help us out if
you're not subscribed please do go ahead
and share this to all your friends if
you can get involved in the discussion
we have a Facebook group in which people
can talk about these subjects I will put
all those links in the description and
also if you can please support us
financially by going to my website
[Music]
www.jfn.co.jp/toho